Zimmermann Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses warum
beschädigen sie den deutschen
Bundeskanzler ihren Kanzler ich habe ihn
in der Tat gewählt aber es geht nicht um
den deutschen Bundeskanzler es geht auch
nicht um die Gefühle von Frau Strack
Zimmermann es geht darum dass wir seit
11 Monaten einen aggressiven schlimmen
Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine
erleben was uns nicht nur menschlich
nicht egal sein kann sondern es ist auch
ein Angriff auf unsere Freiheit auf
unser System auf die Demokratie und dass
man darüber diskutiert auch in einer
Regierung was zu tun ist das finde ich
das zutiefst demokratisch und das werden
wir auch in Zukunft tun denn es geht ja
darum letztlich einen Weg zu gehen wie
können wir die Ukraine letztlich
unterstützen das sind schon harte Sätze
die sie sagen sie sagen der
Bundeskanzler Deutschland hat historisch
versagt warum tun sie das in einer
Situation in der Sie ja wissen müssten
dass der Bundeskanzler das ganze
Gegenteil tut nämlich verhandelt also
sie müssen als Chefin dieses
Verteidigungsausschuss das ist ja wissen
dass der Bundeskanzler gerade genau in
dieser Sache eben mit den US-Amerikanern
beispielsweise verhandelt oder den
Engländern verhandelt warum beschädigen
sie ihren Bundeskanzler also erstmal
artikuliere ich nicht als
verteidigungsausschussvorsitzende das
kann ich gar nicht ersetzen sechs
Parteien da ist die Ampel dass die
cdu/csu da sind die Linken und die AFD
da gibt es deutliche Unterschiede in der
Wahrnehmung dieses Krieges vor allem was
die Linken und die Rechten betrifft das
heißt ich artikuliere mich als freie
Demokratin das ist schon ein Unterschied
und ich bin der Meinung dass ohne jetzt
die Vergangenheit wieder aufzurollen da
ist jetzt alles gesagt und wir gucken
jetzt nach vorne dass ich schon der
Meinung bin dass die Frage wie wir im
Bündnis gesehen werden eine Rolle spielt
es ist ja ein Kompliment dass man
Deutschland auch bei unserer Geschichte
zutraut dass wir führen gemeinsam
arbeiten mit unseren Verbündeten wurde
ja unterstellt das passiert nicht
natürlich muss das sein insofern ist das
auch wissenswert dass wir jetzt
gemeinsam etwas machen aber es ist
glaube ich die Diskussion die sich
aufgehängt hat war glaube ich welche
Rolle können wir übernehmen und welche
Rolle erwarten auch die Partner sowohl
in der EU als auch in der NATO von uns
und ich war in den Vereinigten Staaten
ich habe viele Gespräche geführt die
Erwartungshaltung ist nicht nur dort
auch in Europa sehr deutlich Deutschland
hat eine starke Volkswirtschaft und man
erwartet dass wir ja aber sie fragen und
dann muss man schon erklären warum
sollen sie auch oder was der was der
Punkt ist an dem man solche Situationen
also wenn sie sagen dass Deutschland vor
der Geschichte versagt hat dann steht ja
eigentlich einem Koalitionsbruch wenig
im Wege Frau Zimmermann dann könnten sie
jetzt völlig März folgen und unter einem
Kanzler Friedrich Merz wären die Panzer
vielleicht schon längst nein also ein
Friedrich Merz zu folgen also bei allem
Respekt das wollen wir uns jetzt nicht
übertreiben nein darum geht es überhaupt
nicht schauen Sie es gibt keine
Regierung in der Bundesrepublik nach 19
45 erstmal eine Dreierkonstellation die
schon in sich gesehen wie wie alle
dreierkonstellationen nicht einfach ist
es gibt keine Bundesregierung die einen
solchen Situation ins Auge hat gucken
müssen der Kanzler zurecht von
zeitenwände gesprochen ich würde sogar
weitergehen ich glaube es ist eine
Epochenwende wie wir in Zukunft in
Europa und darüber hinaus leben werden
und ich fand an dem Abend als die
Verteidigungsminister in Ramstein
zusammengekommen sind fand ich es
bedauerlich dass dort nicht ein Ergebnis
mitgeteilt wurde denn das was ein paar
Tage später kam also erst kam es durch
den durch die Presse und dann am
nächsten Morgen also gestern wurde es
dann bestätigt das wäre an dem Tag in
Ramstein natürlich der richtige
Augenblick gewesen dort waren alle
zusammen zu sagen wir haben das und das
vor es war in dem Moment kam wieder
nichts und ich glaube dass auch im
Hinblick auf die Erwartungshaltung der
Menschen da hätte mehr kommen müssen
dass das Thema jetzt erstmal ab viel
mehr erfahren was unter anderem auch in
Ramstein offensichtlich passiert ist
Ralf Stegner ist bei uns Herr Stegner
sie haben für uns die SPD natürlich
kämpfend und streiten sie haben Frau
stark Zimmermann immer beschimpft und
gesagt dass sie dass sie zu denen gehört
die uns in diesen Krieg hineingeredet
haben und hineinreden wollen jetzt sagen
sie sie finden gut was dem Bundeskanzler
da gelogen ist gelungen ist das ist
tatsächlich auch eine persönlich ganz
schön heftige Wände ich habe nicht das
hat nicht gesagt haben sie andere Leute
zitiert dann habe ich nicht gesagt ich
habe Sympathie verleidenschaft und dass
man in der Koalition Überfahren von
Krieg und Frieden miteinander
miteinander Weg miteinander reden das
finde ich normal muss sagen der Punkt
ist ein anderer der Punkt ist nämlich
der ja das Frau Zimmermann in der Sache
ja gehört hat am Ende kommt ein gutes
Ergebnis heraus der Bundeskanzler ist
jemand der dafür sorgt dass er
einerseits die Ukraine unterstützen so
gut wir können andererseits darauf
achten dass der kriegt sie nicht
aushalten Kriegspartei werden und
drittens darauf guckt dass wir gemeinsam
mit den Verbünden handeln und die Bürger
und Bürger auf der Straße die sich uns
überhaupt nicht nach Friedrich Merz oder
Söder so einem Kanzleramt sehen sind
sehr zufrieden
jemanden zu haben der bei Fragen von
Krieg und Frieden die Nerven behält die
müssen nicht auf die darauf ankommt das
wird jetzt in Paris inszeniert oder ein
Rammstein oder sonst so sondern wir
machen das genau dann wenn ich mich
geeinigt habe mit dem Joe Biden und das
was ich besprechen mit macron oder mit
beiden das ist nicht in Wettbewerb und
Twitter Beliebtheit und in der Community
da geht's nicht um Presseerklärung
sondern da geht's
Auseinandersetzung in der Ampel ist ja
jetzt eine logische Frage ich glaube gar
nicht schlecht
Zimmermann in der Öffentlichkeit Agnes
Maria Zimmermann alles gut in der
Öffentlichkeit gesagt hat auch dem
Ansehen des Bundeskanzler weil sie ihm
erst ein Zögern vorgeworfen hat und nun
fällt da um das ist jeweils beides nicht
besonders schön ja aber ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen auch nicht überschätzen am
Ende diese tagespolitischen
Aufgeregtheiten das eine ob das richtig
in der Sache aber entscheiden die
Geschichtsbücher und es ist eine
Situation die es enorm herausfordernd
wir reden nicht über Kleinigkeiten so
lustig hier Filmchen auch fand muss ich
aber auch sagen finde auch dass die
free the Leopards und solche Sachen das
als wenn wieder über Betreuung von
Zootieren reden würden
von Kriegswirtschaft und von
Kriegsbereitschaft sind das total falsch
diese Militarisierung der Sprache und
das Denkens total daneben wir reden
immer noch ernsthafte Angelegenheit die
Bürger und Bürger sind der Meinung dass
sie in der Regierung erwarten können die
ihre Interessen auch vertritt wo Sie
sicher sein können dass da nicht Risiken
herauskommen die nicht so tragen sind
die einerseits den Spagat haben ist ja
wirklich alles tun müssen dass diese
Angriffskrieg keinen Erfolg hat denn das
ist ein eine Verletzung der
Friedensordnung in Europa Grenzen mit
Gewalt zu verschiedenen geht gar nicht
das sind Kriegsverbrecher und trotzdem
vernünftig zu handeln und das tut der
Bundeskanzlerin ist sehr gelassen und
mir fällt das aus auch was frau
Zimmermann sagt oder auch andere auch
her Hofreiter da ist man was sie sagen
und wir gucken mal ich glaube der ist
nicht unzufrieden mit dem was ich sage
wir sind dankbar dass Matthias Gebauer
war es geschätzter Journalistenkollege
vom Spiegel Herr Gebauer ist das jetzt
ein Erfolg diese panzerwände für den
Bundeskanzler und für Deutschland oder
ist es eigentlich eine Blamage
ist ein bisschen von beidem würde ich
sagen ich glaube es ist eine Blamage da
bin ich vor bei Frau Zimmermann dass man
das nicht hinbekommen hat bis Rammstein
und da würde ich Ihnen auch wieder
sprechen er Stegner weil so welche was
sie Symbolik sozusagen nennen das ist in
der internationalen Diplomatie und auch
in so einer Krisensituation schon sehr
wichtig nämlich dass man auch Bilder
produziert und dass man eine
Geschlossenheit auch noch außen
produziert und das ist ja genau das Ziel
von Olaf Scholz was ich voll verstehen
kann dass er sagt er möchte gerne eine
große und auch sozusagen
durchschlagsfähige Koalition vor allem
mit den USA bilden das kann ich total
verstehen aber da ist es eben auch
wichtig am Ende das sozusagen das auch
transportiert wird und das ist gestern
nicht gelungen sondern das Bild ist
eigentlich entstanden und das da können
wir so lange reden wie wir wollen das
Bild in Europa und auch in USA muss man
sich heute nur in den USA die Presse
angucken ist gewesen dass taktiert hat
dass er die Sache verzögert hat und
diesen Stempel sozusagen den wird er
nicht mehr los deswegen würde ich sagen
es ist schon ein Stück weit eine Blamage
auf der anderen Seite habe ich großen
Respekt fast davor tatsächlich wie kühl
und sozusagen also wirklich ganz ruhig
unemotional er erstmal die öffentliche
Kritik ausgehalten hat das finde ich das
gelingt wenigen Politikern wir denken
noch an Gerhard Schröder der hätte das
keine zwei Stunden ausgehalten so eine
Situation ohne zu reagieren aber
gleichwohl
wie sehr hat er sich Herr Gebauer denn
wirklich mit den Amerikanern gestritten
also offensichtlich hat er sicher mit
dem Pentagon gestritten und vielleicht
auch mit dem Außenminister in jedem Fall
aber mit Leute Austin und hat dann mit
wem eine Verständigung gefunden also von
Streit würde ich da nicht sprechen auf
der Ebene wird glaube ich nicht
gestritten da wird es auch nicht laut
auch bei dem Gespräch mit Leuten da war
ja Shorts gar nicht dabei sondern sein
Kanzleramt Chef ist es zumindestens
unseren Informationen auch nicht laut
geworden
sondern man hat Positionen da
ausgetauscht die zu dem Zeitpunkt
konträr waren das Pentagon hat von
Anfang an gesagt wir wollen diese Panzer
nicht liefern aus militärischen Gründen
und am Ende hat Joe Biden glaube ich
eine politische Entscheidung getroffen
und er hat auch das Argument akzeptiert
von Schals erscholz gesagt hat ich
möchte die USA gerne mit im Boot haben
das ist für mich ganz wichtig und das
hat Joe Baden verstanden und hat dann ja
den Rat des Pentagon auch überstimmt das
ist schon sagen wir mal eine sehr
ungewöhnliche Situation habe ich
zumindestens jetzt in meiner Zeit als
Reporter noch nicht so oft erlebt und
das kann man schon auch als Erfolg
werden es geht glaube ich nicht so sehr
darum um Streit oder jemand ist sauer
aufeinander das sind eher so in
politische Themen glaube ich glaube in
dieser Frage ging es wirklich darum es
ist ja noch ausgeschlossen worden
will nicht ausdrücklich widersprechen
ich habe mir das Statement von Joe
beiden angehört was er öffentlich gesagt
hat dann wird jetzt wieder das meinte
der gar nicht was er gesagt ich bedankt
für die von Bundeskanzler hat gesagt wir
haben das Miteinander entschieden das
war sehr wichtig dass das geschieht und
ich habe die New York Times gestern und
heute gelesen haben sie die gleichen
debatten wie in Deutschland auch das
mitnichten so zu sagen das schade jetzt
dem Ansehen Deutschlands die haben die
gleichen Bedenken die haben die gleichen
Fragen und es ist keine Kleinigkeit
zwischen verständigen das ist so dennoch
noch mal interessant nachzufragen
warum eigentlich Olaf Scholz ist so
wichtig war unbedingt die Amerikaner auf
die Seite zu unerträglich davon dass der
neue Verteidigungsminister Pistorius in
Ramstein ja noch sagte er kenne kein
jungteam zwischen dem wir liefern nur
die Leos wenn ihr die Abrams liefert
natürlich musste der
Verteidigungsminister da schon dieses
jungteam kennen auch wenn man es da
vielleicht noch nicht jung genannt hat
also warum war es oder Scholz so wichtig
die Amerikaner an der Seite zu haben das
ist eine muss man sagen strategische
Überlegung die ich nachvollziehen kann
dass er sagt dass er in so einem wenn
man so einen Schritt geht jetzt das noch
mal bei den Waffensystemen doch ein
deutliches Upgrade zu machen deutlich
wirkungsvollere Waffen zu liefern dass
er dann gerne die wichtigen Partner der
Ukraine Unterstützergruppe bei sich
haben will und natürlich vor allen
Dingen die USA
da sind Szenarien die da durchgespielt
werden die sind relativ simpel und die
wird wahrscheinlicher Stegner genauso
sehen wenn Deutschland alleine
vielleicht sogar mit den Polen zusammen
alleine nach vorne gegangen wäre in so
einer Situation hätte Putin einfach die
Chance gehabt uns auch zu exponieren und
hätte natürlich auch sagen können seht
ihr die Koalition fällt auseinander die
Amerikaner wollen keine Panzer liefern
aber Deutschland liefert jetzt und da
muss man glaube ich nicht immer nur vom
Atomkrieg gleich sprechen oder vom
Ausbruch des Dritten Weltkriegs sondern
es gibt ja eine viel kleinere
Möglichkeit auch für Putin Dinge zu
eskalieren wir erinnern uns an die Hand
also sozusagen an die Sabotage Akte
gegen Nord Stream 2 sowas ist jederzeit
wieder möglich es gibt noch ganz viele
andere Parkplätze schon jetzt
komischerweise einen Tag nach der
Entscheidung sehen wir in
rasantenanstieg von Cyber Angriffen die
russischen Gruppen zugeordnet werden das
heißt die Chance oder das Risiko dass
Deutschland dann plötzlich nach einem
alle Studiengang oder nach zumindestens
ohne die USA exponiert da steht das ist
real und das kann glaube ich auch jeder
nachvollziehen ganz egal wie man jetzt
sozusagen das Verhandlungsgeschick von
Olaf Scholz beurteilt oder nicht gut
also weil aber das ist ja ein
interessante Frage weil die Amerikaner
jetzt irgendwann in zehn Monaten eine
gute Handvoll Kampfpanzer ihre
Kampfpanzer dazu packen ist dann Putin
nur noch halb so böse auf uns also das
ist im Grunde genommen kurz gesagt was
sie sagen und ich gebe die Frage gleich
mal an Jana polierin weiter eine
Politikwissenschaftlerin sie haben nicht
nur schon viel in dieser Sendung
gesessen sie haben im September zusammen
mit einem weiteren militär-experten
genau diesen Vorschlag gemacht dass
unter deutscher Führung eben endlich
Kampfpanzer in einem Kontingent für die
Ukraine bereitgestellt werden soll ist
das denn aus ihren Augen jetzt ein
gelungener Erfolg ist das die
panzerwände ist das jetzt der große
Unterschied ich fange vielleicht mal an
mit der europäischen Komponente wir
haben damals im September eine
europäische Koalition vorgeschlagen wir
haben vorgeschlagen dass es 13 Nationen
in der NATO gibt in Europa wenn man die
Türkei mitzählt die liefern könnten und
dass man ein eine gemeinsame Anstrengung
unternehmen kann also dass man
idealerweise Kampfpanzer identifiziert
die vom selben Typ sind und obwohl es
nationale Unterschiede gibt die man
miteinander kombinieren kann um die
logistischen Herausforderungen für die
Ukraine begrenzt zu halten und das
Training gemeinsam zu organisieren um
die Munition gemeinsam zu organisieren
die Idee war also niemals ein Alleingang
Deutschlands da bin ich bei Herrn
Gebauer da kann ich den Kanzler auch
verstehen sondern eine europäische
Alternative weil da schon klar war dass
die Amerikaner
Sympathien hätten für eine Serie maximal
gewesen dass worauf Olaf Scholz ich
hätte einlassen können eben eine solche
europäische Initiative zu führen das
wäre halt das gewesen also
diese Taten auszufüllen was sonst immer
in Deutschland und Europa im Mund
geführt wird nämlich europäische
Souveränität und dass die Europäer mehr
machen um zu europäischen Sicherheit
beizutragen die Amerikaner entlasten und
deswegen ich nicht doch dass ich die
Koalition kommt ja das ist ja das
positive Ergebnis ich würde deswegen
auch tatsächlich ein Stegner Zustimmung
unterm Strich ist das Ergebnis für die
Ukraine mit den Amerikanern ein besseres
als wenn es nur die Europäer alleine
gemacht haben aber Fakt ist auch dass
die Amerikaner bis vor ganz kurzer Zeit
nicht wollten und das z.B die beiden
Administration glaube ich sehr
wohlwollend auf uns und Deutschland
guckt aber ich frag mich auch wie die
Republikaner das Aufnehmen und da ist es
eben so dass der Eindruck sich
verfestigt hat in Washington dass sie
Europäer im Zweifelsfall nur mit dem
großen Bruder an der Hand vorangehen mit
der Schutz macht USA und eben ja dass
sie diese eigenen europäischen
Souveränität und ähm
werden und es gibt ein großes Camp in
den USA die sagen unsere Priorität liegt
auf Asien auf China und darauf müssen
wir uns konzentrieren und man hätte
glaube ich eine europäisches Vorgehen
auch begrüßt in den USA sehr begrüßt in
den USA das wird uns Ben Hodges auch
gleich noch mal bestätigen der ehemalige
Oberkommandierende des us-heeres in
Europa den ich heute herzlich in London
begrüße einen guten Abend nach London
Ben Hoodies und hier ist gleich die
schönen guten Abend die erste Frage es
hat dieses diesen Zickzackkurs eben auch
in der amerikanischen Regierung gegeben
am Ende könnte man sagen die
US-Administration wollte diese
Kampfpanzer eigentlich noch weniger als
Olaf Scholz oder
denke dass das Treffen der Kontaktgruppe
in Ramstein reicht auch eine vertane
Chance mal für die Vereinigten Staaten
aber auch für Deutschland
denn diese Unsicherheit darüber was wir
nun tun hätte nie so auftreten dürfen
ich glaube dass die beiden
Administrationen eine gute Arbeit
geleistet hat in vielen Bereichen aber
trotzdem noch nicht beschlossen hat dass
sie wirklich daran interessiert sind
dass die Ukraine gewinnt man sagt wir
wollen dass die Ukraine nicht verliert
dass Sie erfolgreich sind aber sie
kommen nicht dahin zu sagen die Ukraine
muss gewinnen und deswegen gibt es
dieses Zögern dort auf amerikanischer
Seite
ich denke wenn wir vom Monaten schon
beschlossen hätten dass wir da
interessiert sind dass die Ukraine
gewinnen dann werden wir heute diese
Diskussion nicht mehr dann wären die
Panzer schon geliefert worden und für
Deutschland war das auch
indem man hätte ganz klar sagen können
welche Politik man in Deutschland
verfolgt welches strategische Denken man
hat in Bezug auf die Ukraine das wäre
die Möglichkeit gewesen dass ganz klar
zu stellen das Bundeskanzlers
und auch wäre es eine gute Möglichkeit
gewesen für den neuen
Verteidigungsminister einfach mal zu
sagen was Deutschland tun möchte und
schlussendlich ist es klar geworden und
jetzt brauchen wir auch nicht mehr über
die Kampfpanzer zu sprechen sondern eher
über die Fähigkeiten die notwendig sind
die die Ukraine braucht um zu gewinnen
noch mal eine einen Schritt zurück eben
dennoch zu den Abrahams es ist ein neues
Wort erfunden worden für die Politik des
Bundeskanzlers in Deutschland und zwar
von einem britischen Historiker das
nennt man scholzing wenn man etwas
ankündigt und dann viele viele viele
Maßnahmen Ideen irgendwie erfindet um
das was man angekündigt hat erstmal
nicht zu tun könnte man dieses scholzing
nicht eigentlich ist auch der
US-amerikanischen Regierung vorwerfen
auch die US-Amerikaner wollten nicht den
Abrahams liefern
schauen Sie die Vereinigten Staaten
haben enorme Mengen an
Ausrüstungsgegenstand von Hilfe bereits
geliefert
ja blinken und der Verteidigungsminister
aus den Präsident haben hervorragende
Arbeit geleistet nämlich sie haben alle
der Nation über 50 von den um diese
Fähigkeiten gemeinsam zu liefern ich
glaube schon die Einheit die Einigkeit
die natürlich sehr schwierig war zu
erreichen und die Tatsache dass die
Vereinigten Staaten Deutschland
Großbritannien gemeinsam jetzt Panzer
liefern ist wahrscheinlich sogar noch
wichtiger als die Panzer selber
ich glaube die Administration
ist sich noch nicht so richtig sicher
dass die Ukraine wirkliche gewinnen soll
dass das der Wunsch der Amerikaner ist
dass sie auch sich die Krim wieder
zurückholen das müssen wir ganz klar
darstellen und dann ist die Frage der
Ausrüstungsgegenstände eigentlich an
Selbstläufer und dazu kommen wir
natürlich noch weil es auch diese Idee
eben schon gibt das nach den
Kampfpanzern jetzt tatsächlich auch die
Kampfjets ein nächster Zug wären um die
Ukraine genau dazu befähigen dazu kommen
wir noch franz Alt ist bei uns und das
freut uns sehr Publizist Pazifist und
Autor wir sind Franz Alt da muss ich und
möchte ich den Christen Fragen und den
Pazifisten Fragen jetzt in einer
Situation wo man
nichts zitierend Halleluja ruft weil
endlich Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine
geschickt werden und nun also
tatsächlich gute Waffen doch dazu da
sind Frieden zu schaffen
die Position der Friedensbewegung das
Wort Frieden ist noch nicht gefallen
nach
bei einer 20 über 20 Minuten in unserer
Sendung jetzt
die Position der Friedensbewegung hieß
Frieden schaffen oder was aber jetzt
haben wir eine neue Situation wir alle
gegen auch in der Friedensbildung wir
machen auch alle an diesem Tisch davon
aus dass es einen so schrecklichen Krieg
nicht mehr geben wird in Europa
wenn wir eine neue Situation haben und
die haben wir da muss auch die
Friedensbewegung umdenken
und auch mal Eingehen auf die Position
Frieden schaffen mitwaffen das ist
zumindest ich nenne das realpazifismus
meine Position ich wenn wir nicht Waffen
geliefert hätten bisher schon wie sehr
die Ukraine dann heute auch
wahrscheinlich gäbe ich sie Ukraine als
Staat und das das Volk gar nicht mehr
putinen hätte alles klein und kurz
geschlagen das macht er ja fast jeden
Tag die Bilder sind kaum auszuhalten die
wir sehen aber ich denke halt in der
jetzigen Situation reden wir wie in
dieser Sendung zu sehr über Krieg und
Waffen und Waffensysteme oder Waffen
Waffen und zu wenig über die
Möglichkeiten doch in einer ganz
schwierigen Situation zu Verhandlungen
zu kommen zu einem Waffenstillstand das
erste Schritt und zweitens zu einem
wirklichen Friedensvertrag dass das
immer möglich ist hat Gorbatschow uns
vorgemacht in einer Situation indem er
in Amerika mit einem kalten Krieger
nichts zu tun hatte das verrecken hat er
Vertrauen aufgebaut so hatte mir mal
erzählt in einem gemeinsamen Buch das
wir geschrieben haben hat er das
verdeutlicht er hat Vertrauen aufgebaut
dass ich mit Putin schwieriger da bin
ich auf ihrer Seite weiß Gott zu
vergleichen
war auch kein Pazifist er war ein kalter
Krieger und trotzdem war das Gorbatschow
geschafft in dazu zu bringen abzurüsten
und ich habe ihn gefragt Herr
Gorbatschow wir haben Sie das gemacht
dann sagte wir haben Vertrauen
zueinander aufgebaut das versuchen wir
zu wenig jetzt bei Putin es ist
schwierig weiß Gott aber wenn man immer
sagen Putin geht das nicht dann kommt
auch nicht zustande wir haben erlebt vor
wenigen Wochen in Afrika der eine der
schlimmsten Kriege nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg in Äthiopien bürgerkriegt mit
Millionen Flüchtlingen mit zehntausenden
von Toten die haben sich zusammengesetzt
ein kleines Politik oder ein großes
politisches Wunder haben sich plötzlich
mit Brüder angesprochen das ist mit
Putin nichts zu machen da gebe ich Ihnen
gleich recht aber haben es geschafft
immerhin einen Vertrag zustande zu
bringen der sich selber Friedensvertrag
ein fragiler Frieden noch das dauert
aber man sieht auch in scheinbar
ausweglose Situationen ist Frieden noch
immer möglich und die Tatsache dass man
zu wenig darüber reden er stört mich
sehr obwohl ich für Waffenlieferungen
bin als Pazifist fällt mir das weiß Gott
nicht leicht also wir haben das nicht
tut in dieser Situation ist es
unterlassene Hilfeleistung da kann ich
mich auch als christlich auf die
Bergpredigt Berufen ich musste Ukraine
in dieser Situation helfen unter
Umständen auch ist alles geben mit
schweren Waffen wie jetzt mit dem Leben
wir müssen schon deshalb alles geben um
nicht schuld an einer Niederlage der
Ukraine zu sein wenn man es denn so
formulieren möchte muss auf eine alt ist
egal noch gar nicht auf dem Weg den sie
gerade beschrieben haben
die Regierung putin hatte heute nichts
besseres zu tun als sofort zu sagen dass
natürlich jetzt eine noch größere
Eskalation Vorschläge das jetzt also ein
direkter Eingriff und ein Einsteigen der
Deutschen in diesen Krieg offenbar würde
und darauf reagieren Menschen natürlich
auch macht ihnen das Angst besorgt sie
das die Frage ist beim Thema Angst dass
die das Thema Angst fällt mir das Wort
Angst fällt mir zu häufig in der ganzen
Diskussion die Frage ist doch müssen wir
Grund haben vor Angst gestern gab es
eine Meldung bei einer zeitgleich mit
der Scholz Entscheidung
ein amerikanisches wissenschaftliches
Gremium dass ich dummstee
Gesellschaft nennt also
weltuntergangsituation hat gesagt wir
sind noch nie so nah an einem Weltkrieg
an einem Atomkrieg gewesen 90 Sekunden
vor zwölf ist die weltuntergangsuhr
jetzt gestellt übrigens beiden hat das
vor wenigen Wochen schon gesagt die Welt
ist wegen des Ukraine Krieges noch nie
so nah an einem Atomkrieg also an
Weltuntergang muss man sagen gestanden
wie seit der Kuba-Krise vor etwas 60
Jahren wenn man ernst nehmen da kann man
nicht sagen das ist nur Angst ja
natürlich haben wir Grund vor Angst die
Welt ist voller Atombomben mit der
Atombomben die wir heute noch haben
könnte man mindestens 20 mal die gesamte
Menschheit vernichten also es gibt Grund
zu Fuß mindestens so vorsichtig zu sein
die Kanzler Scholz ist wahr mir ist ein
Kanzler der in bei Überlieferungen
zögert und zaudert lieber als ein
Draufgänger sind wir jetzt bei einer
Eskalation Frau Zimmermann weil und eine
Eskalation auch unsererseits weil
deutsche Panzer auf Russen schießen
werden und natürlich die Befürchtung im
Raum steht dass jenseits der putinisten
in Russland auch Menschen die überhaupt
keine Fans von Vladimir Putin waren
plötzlich anders auf diesen Krieg gucken
ist das auch in ihrem Denken nein das
ist die Geschichte Wladimir Putins das
ist die Geschichte der deutsche Panzer
auf ukrainischen Grund und Boden da wird
ja bewusst sozusagen mental auf den
Zweiten Weltkrieg hingewiesen deutsche
Wehrmacht in Deutschland ich habe war
zweimal in der Ukraine und diese Frage
habe ich die Soldaten dort und auch die
PolitikerInnen die wir getroffen haben
Zivilgesellschaft gefragt wie sie den
Blick eigentlich auf einen deutschen
panz haben da geht es ja um die
hardwares ein Panzer der in Deutschland
gebaut wird der korrekt hat halber im
Panzer sitzen ukrainische Soldaten das
muss man immer wieder hervorheben und
alle haben sofort gesagt das ist euer
euer Geschichtsverständnis da waren die
deutschen Panzer und jetzt 80 Jahre
später wieder keiner in der Ukraine
macht sich Gedanken über die Geschichte
im Gegenteil sondern die
Erwartungshaltung dass wir als sehr
starke Nation wirtschaftlich starke
Nation im Herzen Europas ja auch aus dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg gestärkt
demokratischer vorgegangen dass man
gerade bei uns schaut dass eben jetzt
mit allem möglichen helfen sollte und
die Geschichte dass der deutsche Panzer
jetzt in der Ukraine ist ist die
Geschichte die Wladimir Putin erzählt
denn was er jetzt erzählt das ist jetzt
nicht erstaunlich erträgt jetzt die
Geschichte um und sagt seinen Menschen
sieht ihr da sind sie wieder die
Deutschen vor unserer Grenze und ich
persönlich warne davor
großen Respekt Angst ist ein schlechter
Ratgeber aber vorsicht ist angesagt dass
man diese Geschichte nicht selber
erzählt die er anfängt zu erzählen um im
Nachhinein zu rechtfertigen ich habe die
Ukraine pro forma überfallen weil jetzt
passiert ist jetzt kommt der Westen auf
uns zu ich habe es euch immer gesagt
sprechen finde ich und trotzdem werden
wir unsere Geschichte nicht los vor
stark Zimmermann man kann auch die
Geschichte erzählen in Deutschland ist
jetzt schon nach Amerika mit Abstand der
zweitgrößte Unterstützer der Ukraine wir
sind das overall sowieso wir sind
militärisch mit dem Briten zusammen auch
mit den zusammen auch aber ist allein
auf das militärische zu verengen vor
ziemlich genau 80 Jahren war Stalingrad
100.000 Tote dort und wir werden unsere
Geschichte nicht los deswegen bin ich
der Meinung dass wir zwar helfen und
dass er auch mit militärischer ich habe
dazu geschrieben im Deutschen Bundestag
aber das ist uns nicht leicht machen und
erst recht nicht mit immer mehr und
immer offensichtlich auch die Frage
stellen muss zulassen muss jedenfalls ob
die Panzer Kampfpanzer wirklich den
Krieg schneller beenden oder nicht nur
zu mehr Toten führen die Frage muss man
stellen dürfen und man muss gleichzeitig
sagen es gibt auch noch andere Dinge und
Diplomatie heißt ja nicht direkt mit dem
Putin zu verhandeln sondern Diplomatik
kann zum Beispiel etwas heißen wofür wir
kritisiert worden sind nach China zu
gehen den zu sagen die haben vielleicht
mehr Einfluss auf Russland als wir das
haben die haben die Wirtschaftskrise mit
Corona die störte der kriegt ja mit dem
Westen nichts gemeint aber das Ergebnis
war immer nach dem Peking war dass der
chinesische Staatspräsident sich
hinstellt und den Rosen gesagt hört man
Aufklärung von glasklare Ansage die
hatten wir vorher so noch nicht und
deswegen glaube ich die Einseitigkeit
immer nur über neue Waffensysteme zu
reden und überhaupt nicht zu bedenken
dass das natürlich auch ein Punkt hat
der egal was der Putin erzählt
Eskalation Gefahren in sich birgt und
damit besonders umzugehen das ist eben
Teil der Klugheit und eben nicht nur
über Waffen zu reden und manchmal habe
ich den Eindruck wir haben ganz viele
neue Militär Experten in Deutschland
plötzlich eben war es noch Leute die
über die Ideologie
aber das ist nämlich das mal zu Ende
sein der Punkt ist wenn wir nur wenn wir
nur geschafft liebe Frau Zimmermann wenn
man nur über Waffen redet und nur ein
militärischen Denken verhaftet ist fehlt
dann möglicherweise die Fantasie auch
andere Wege zu gehen da da alt völlig
Recht und letzter Satz weil du das
Beispiel genannt hat gerade die Cora
Krise und Kennedy ist ein Beispiel dafür
da weil die Stimmung genauso ganz viel
Druck der hat mit großer geschickt lernt
aus dem ersten Weltkrieg gesagt man muss
sich in die Perspektiven der anderen
versetzen auch wenn man sie nicht teilt
hat mit dem
kunststoffsicherungsverständlich was
nicht öffentlich kommuniziert worden ist
und hat den dritten Weltkriegen das ist
eine große historische
keiner verengt das auf militärische
deutschland ist der größte
wirtschaftliche Unterstützer humanitär
übrigens auch in ganz praktischen Dingen
der Angriff Putins auf die Infrastruktur
ist Deutschland deutsche Unternehmen die
entsprechende Material liefern dass
Menschen heizen können und nicht
erfrieren das ist gar nicht das Thema
sondern das Thema ist wie gehen wir in
einer solchen Situation um und wenn man
über Diplomatie spricht hat man ja ein
Kompromiss Augen wenn ich oder
irgendjemand zu ihnen sagen würde ich
will sie umbringen ich will dass sie weg
sind das sagen sie dann der Kompromiss
ist dass ich ihre Arme nehme oder ihre
Beine oder ihr Rumpf übrig bleibt und
deswegen bin ich und meine Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Freien Demokraten um
das jetzt nicht auf den Ausschuss
runterzubrechen sind der Meinung dass
wenn es Gespräche geben sollte wobei ich
nicht ganz ihrem beinung bin Wladimir
Putin und Ronald Reagan zu vergleichen
ich finde das ist ein sehr kühner
Vergleich auch historisch hinter der
wenn man an Gespräche überhaupt denken
kann und das werden die Ukraine
entscheiden dann nur aus der stärker
heraus das Wladimir Putin erkennt dass
das was er vor hatte nicht funktioniert
und auf der Basis kann man aufbauen
ansonsten halte ich das in der jetzigen
Phase für Hochschule erhalten sie haben
vielleicht nehmen wir lieber diesen
historischen Vergleich sie hatten mit
gorbatsch hoffen natürlich auch über
Putin geredet und Gorbatschow hat
Angela Merkel getroffen und hat ihm
geschildert ihn und geschildert das
Putin lügt und lügt und lügt und das ist
ganz schwer ist sich mit ihm zu treffen
und da war die Reaktion von Gorbatschow
wie Gorbatschow hat gesagt der Westen
hat
mehrere große Fehler gemacht und die
Fehler des Westens in den letzten 30
Jahren kommen wir in all diesen
Diskussionen viel zu kurz ich mal drei
Namen neben Gorbatschow Kohl und Helmut
Schmidt ich nehme an wir sind in dieser
Runde einig das sind alles Realpolitiker
keine verrückten Pazifisten wie ich oder
so
Helmut Schmidt hat
mehrfach gesagt öffentlich wir nehmen zu
wenig Rücksicht auf die
Sicherheitsinteressen von Putin und von
Russland ich will mal zitieren was
Helmut Kohl gesagt hat zu diesem Thema
helmut Kohl hat in einem Buch
über Europa 2014 geschrieben
2015 auf Nachfragen von Journalisten
gesagt wir müssen Putin mehr ernst
nehmen als bisher wir müssen mit Putin
mehr reden es war falsch Russland aus
der G8 auszuschließen und die G7 zu
gründen die Sicherheitsinteressen
Russlands Helmut kohlwörtlich die
Sicherheitsinteressen Russland sind für
die Sicherheit Europas
unglaublich wichtig damals hätte man mit
Putin noch reden müssen heute ist es
immer schwieriger also ich bin völlig
der Meinung dieser Runde was die heutige
Politik Putins angesprochen aber wir
haben mehrere Fehler gemacht Frau Merkel
hat versucht und hat im Gorbatschow dann
gesagt er hat es mir bestätigt er lügt
er lügt er lügt wissen Sie was
Gorbatschows Antwort war das war ihre
Frage an mich versuchen sie trotzdem den
Draht zu halten es ist wichtig für den
Frieden in Europa und jetzt können wir
nämlich sofort verstehen und genau
diesen historischen Gedanken wollte ich
so gerne in die Runde holen es ist ja
Herr Gebauer viel verhandelt worden auf
den berühmten geheimen Wegen haben ja im
November und Dezember die vier großen
versucht nach Moskau hin alles
anzubieten was auch nur in Ansätzen ein
Entgegenkommen in Bezug auf die
Sicherheitsbedürfnisse Russlands gewesen
sind mit welchem Ergebnis
also das spielte ja damals dann auch gar
keine Rolle mehr da war der Krieg ja in
Vorbereitung auch wenn wir uns das alle
nicht eingestanden haben
Deutschen Bundestag alle Parteien von
rechts und jetzt sind wir bei 20 22
applaudiert haben also für das Ende des
Kalten Krieges sich einsetzt
ist also wir müssen ja richtig aus der
jetzigen Zeit heraus sehen
aber wollen sie wollen sich wollen Sie
wirklich der Theorie folgen
mit Putin muss ich mich in
hineinversetzen anders geht es nicht da
muss ich jetzt mal ganz kurz rein 20 15
erste Angriff auf die Ostukraine mit
15.000 Menschen gestorben da wurde
Angela Merkel darauf angesprochen warum
Deutschland nicht mehr sanktioniert oder
hatte sie ganz deutlich gesagt nein man
muss ja die Sicherheitsinteressen
verstehen Putin schwarz mehr Flotte dass
er daran kann und hat dann trotzdem auf
dem Weg gebracht das war ein Abkommen
Deutschland Russland an der Ukraine
vorbei zum Schaden der Ukraine und an
den europäischen Partnern vorbei also
der Bundesregierung damals zu sagen sie
hätten mit Putin nicht gesprochen das
haben sie aber sie haben verkannt was er
letztlich und jetzt geschrieben er hat
das gesagt er hat es immer wieder gesagt
was er letztlich will die Sowjetunion
aber das ist doch der entscheidende
Punkt es geht ja vielleicht gar nicht so
sehr um die Sicherheitsinteressen von
Russland und die NATO in diesem Fall
wenn man Artikel liest den Putin 2021
geschrieben hat wenn man die reden hört
die er gehalten hat jetzt kurz vor dem
Krieg und auch währenddessen dann geht
es ihm darum dass er sagt die Ukraine
und Russland sind ein Volk eine Nation
er sagt die Ukraine ist nicht souverän
sondern im Prinzip in Geiselhaft von
diesem selensky-regime und die wahre
Ukraine will eigentlich nach Russland
ich glaube fakt ist einfach dass er
versucht den Zerfall eines Imperiums
oder den Rest davon wenn er Belarus und
die Ukraine dazu zählt diesen Zerfall
aufzuhalten das sieht man in der
Reaktion auf die Proteste in Belarus
damals das sieht man bei der Ukraine es
geht darum diese Länder
zu halten den
einflussabkommens von Russland immer die
Kontrolle über kieft zu erreichen durch
dann jetzt und lukanz das war das Ziel
Stream 2 hatten nun nennenswert eben
allem was eigentlich unsere Interessen
sind ja sehr geschadet wir haben darüber
in dieser Sendung schon viel geredet und
haben ehrlich gesagt ja auch noch so
viel zu besprechen vor allen Dingen eben
auch über dich die Situation in Europa
ich muss jetzt noch mal zu Frau polierin
oder Herrn Gebauer marschieren weil ja
so interessant ist wie sehr die
Deutschen auch vorgeworfen bekamen so
allein in Europa zu sein das ist glaube
ich auch für die Zuschauer noch mal ein
wichtiger Punkt zu verstehen die Polen
haben dem deutschen Bundeskanzler große
Vorwürfe gemacht Frau polierin und wir
stellen jetzt fest dass in diesem großen
Raum der Unterstützer mit Kampfpanzern
wahnsinnig viele europäische Länder
erstmal nicht mit dabei sind die
Italiener nicht mit dabei die
Österreicher nicht die Schweizer nicht
die Spanier haben Schwierigkeiten die
Franzosen wollen auch nicht so gerne
warum ist eigentlich den deutschen
vorgeworfen worden dass sie
da so alleine stünden in Europa es gab
viele die gezögert haben also ich finde
die Deutschen haben einen Punkt gehabt
sehr lange zu sagen keine andere
Nationen liefert Kampf und
Schützenpanzer ich glaube die Deutschen
spielen eine besondere Rolle wenn es
gerade um den Leopard 2 geht weil sie
eben da auch die Kontrolle über den
Export haben und das wurde dann eben
akut als Polen den Export angefragt hat
ich glaube was von Deutschland erwartet
wurde war was der Kanzler in einem vorne
versartikel gesagt hat eben
hauptgarant europäischer Sicherheit zu
sein und deswegen stand Deutschland
glaube ich da immer in der besonderen
Verantwortung aber ich konnte sehr wohl
verstehen dass die Bundesregierung nicht
alleine vorangehen wollte was ich
schwierig fand war jetzt in der jüngsten
Vergangenheit dass die Briten ja gesagt
haben sie liefern die Challenger dass
vorher ja die Entscheidung schon
gefallen war für die Schützenpanzer wo
die Franzosen für die spielpanzer die
Franzosen liefern und das hier im
Vorfeld von Rammstein z.B auch der
finnische Präsident gesagt hat Finnland
wäre an Bord wenn es einen europäisches
Konsortium lebe und das wäre jetzt quasi
meine Kritik wobei ich im Endeffekt
sagen muss wenn wir ganz ehrlich sind
und auf die Zahlen der verfügbaren
Panzer in Europa gucken auch der Leopard
2 Panzer dann ist ist es ein knappes Gut
30 Jahre Friedensdividende haben ihren
Preis gehabt und deswegen ist es unterm
Strich auch wenn ich die Methodik
vielleicht ein bisschen brachial fand
die USA so an Bord zu holen unterm
Strich für die Ukraine auch eine gute
Nachricht dass die USA in ja
wahrscheinlich 18 12 Monaten auch mit
Kampfpanzern sich engagieren werden
einfach weil dieser Krieg wenn er noch
länger dauert ja sehr viel
Verluste nicht nur an Menschen sondern
auch an Material nach sich zieht und da
ist es einfach wichtig wenn wir die
Ukraine kontinuierlich unterstützen
wollen die Amerikaner auch einfach wir
stellen gleich die Frage noch mal an
bennox ist und ich möchte trotzdem noch
eine Sekunde bei den Europäern bleiben
wenn eigentlich klar war Herr Gebauer
dass die Polen und Entschuldigung dass
die Deutschen
Vorhaben eben tatsächlich diese
Koalition zu bilden warum haben dann die
Polen noch so ein Theater gemacht was
ich der Kanzler nicht geäußert hat das
ist für mich eines der größten Rätsel
ehrlich gesagt also wenn man jetzt im
Nachhinein weiß und das Zeichnen wir
morgen noch mal relativ genau nach wie
lange darüber schon gesprochen worden
ist ganz intensiv mit den USA aber auch
mit den Briten und den Franzosen also
mindestens seit Weihnachten in der ganz
konkreten Form deswegen habe ich mich
jetzt im Nachhinein gefragt warum z.B
bei so einem Treffen wie in Rammstein
warum er Herr Pistorius da nicht mit
einer klaren Botschaft hingeschickt hat
die lautet wir sind jetzt noch nicht bei
einer Einigung aber wir reden intensiv
er hat sich dann in so sag mal etwas
magere Sätze geflüchtet im Nachhinein
hat man sie dann verstanden er hat ja da
schon immer gesagt es könnte
möglicherweise eine Entscheidung in
wenigen Stunden oder Tagen geben wo wir
alle ein bisschen Rätseln da stand und
dachten was was meint er damit aber
warum er da also warum der Bundeskanzler
sich da nicht einfach einmal eingelassen
hat er hätte ja nicht konkret werden
müssen worüber man genau redet aber
hätte ja sagen können wir sind im
Gespräch Kommunikation zum Beispiel
hätte er ja auch seine engsten
Koalitionäre und dazu würde ich jetzt
Frau Zimmermann einfach mal zählen als
Vorsitzende des verteilungsausschusses
die ich glaube so viel Vertrauen ist ja
noch da wenn dann Zuruf da gewesen wäre
hör mal zu wir sprechen darüber aber
halte ich ein bisschen bedeckt
öffentlich dann hätte man ja auch diese
verbalen soll ich mal diesen verbalen
Boxkampf ein bisschen ausbremsen können
und das also das verstehe ich nicht
widersprechen man kann Kommunikation
immer besser machen aber wir reden die
ständig über die Kommunikation dass der
Urlaub sagt wir sagen dass wenn das
fertig ist wird entschuldigen wenn er
mir sagen was wenn wir fertig sind und
nicht auf dem Weg und dann interessiert
mich nicht ob der eine Druckausübung
man hat ganz viel öffentlich kommentiert
die ganzen Monate lang
ich muss ehrlich sagen ich vertraue
meinem Bundeskanzler wenn der in
Gespräch mit dem amerikanischen
Präsidenten ist und es verbietet sich
über manche Erwägung öffentlich zu reden
wie ich auch ganz deutlich sagen dann
kann man das den Pudding gleich sagen
was man alles vor hat das verbietet sich
sondern dann zu kommen wenn man sich
geeinigt hat die drei Tage hält die
Öffentlichkeit aus ich sage Ihnen nicht
man trifft viele Menschen auf der Straße
ich mache seit 30 Jahren Politik ich
habe noch nie so viel Zustimmung aus der
Bevölkerung bekommen für diese Haltung
die sagen immer sagen sie am Kanzler
soll bitte dabei bleiben er soll sich
nicht drängen lassen es geht nicht darum
jetzt irgendwie Pressekonferenzen zu
erreichen sondern sich in der Sache zum
verständigen und es ist nicht eine
Kleinigkeit sich mit Amerika zu einiges
haben Sie ja selbst geschildert wo die
hergekommen sind und das ist jetzt sehr
viel wert dass wir das gemeinsam haben
und es geht auch nicht immer nur um die
neueste Waffen Gattung an dem Tag als
wir den den Schützenpanzer Maler
geliefer kann die sofort die Debatte los
jetzt müssen aber die Kampfpanzer kommen
jetzt haben wir die kampfans sofort im
Flugzeuge geht um Kampfschiff von also
was soll das eigentlich hinführen wir
Schützenpanzer aber das Besonderheit in
solchen Sachen rechtlichen zusammen das
ist eine militärische Logik
davon haben wir zu viel wir
Schützenpanzer und der Kampfpanzer ist
eine militärische Logik wirken zusammen
hat nichts mit Flugzeugen zu tun hat
nichts mit Schiffen zu tun das ist eine
völlige Gegner die Frauen die man darf
auch nicht doch einfach sein der Krieg
dauert jetzt noch ewig einen Krieg
halt's Mord Zerstörung Verfolgung
Vergewaltigung Elend für die Leute der
kriegt werden
dass sie viel wichtigere Fragen also
sind Verständnisfragen alt und sie sind
ja auch wichtig weil sie unsere jetzigen
und zukünftigen Koalitionspartner
betrifft mit denen wir zusammen ja
dieses Problem lösen und dann muss man
ja wenigstens im Ziel einig sein und man
wissen muss wissen mit welchen
Intentionen man unterwegs ist und was
ich fragte ist das offensichtlich viele
andere europäische Länder Vorschlag
Zimmermann hier ist noch mal die Frage
auch kalte Füße hatten oder aber andere
Gründe hatten warum sie nicht so viel
jetzt beitragen wie sie in der
öffentlichen Diskussion Vorgaben
beizutragen also wie einig oder wie
gespalten ist dieses Europa tatsächlich
und wie allein stand da der
Bundeskanzler also wir haben 14 Länder
in Europa die den Leopard 2 haben
übrigens die Anzahl heute entspricht der
Anzahl die wir vor 1990 allein in
Deutschland hatten da sieht man wie das
zusammen
ähnlich das geworden ist und Deutschland
muss das den Leopard herstellt die
Erlaubnis geben wenn also Deutschland in
dem Fall der Bundeskanzler gesagt hätte
grundsätzlich genehmige ich dass unsere
Partner das machen das war ja das auch
was Polen gewartet hat und wir sind noch
im Gespräch mit den Vereinigten Staaten
und deswegen dauert es noch ein paar
Tage und dann werden wir verkünden wie
das Ergebnis ist wäre der ganze Druck
draußen gewesen und die europäische
taten die europäischen die europäischen
Partner die ein Interesse bekundet haben
wie Finnland später kam auch Dänemark
dazu übrigens auch die baltischen
Staaten die den Leopard 2 fahren haben
artikuliert dass sie auf grünes Licht
aus Deutschland warten das macht
natürlich auch Sinn weil sie dürfen
nicht vergessen Freunde da sprechen ja
viel kleinere Länder die natürlich ein
viel geringeres Potenzial haben als wir
und ich habe ganz positiv immer gehört
dass Deutschland der in anderen
Bereichen sehr selbstbewusst und gerne
führt dass sie diesen dieses grüne Licht
brauchen und das natürlich nicht geht
dass wir sagen ihr könnt das machen ihr
könnt das machen und wir nicht also es
ist letztendlich eine Frage der
Kommunikation dabei ist die Maus keinen
Faden ab übrigens nicht nur intern da
kann man ja mit umgehen ob wir
diskutieren
wird
vergessen Sie Ihre Rede nicht vor 14
Tagen als auch vor drei Tagen Annalena
bärburg ja sagten die die Panzer liefern
wollen bekommen natürlich die
Genehmigung später ist sie wieder
zurückgerudert also es war eine hatte es
14 Tage zuvor gesagt noch mal die Frage
Herr Stegner kommuniziert dann also ein
Kanzler nicht mit seinem Vizekanzler und
nicht mit seiner Außenministerin das
wäre ja schön und auch wichtig doch das
tut er natürlich schon aber ich muss
ganz ehrlich sein dieser Aufgeregtheit
wer hat wann was erfahren in einer
Koalition die weiß worauf man sich
verständigt hat wo die Prinzipien gelten
die wir machen die muss es auch
aushalten dass bestimmte Dinge nur
zwischen den Bundeskanzlerin Präsidenten
und den Patienten Frankreichs besprochen
wird wo sie auch dann finde ich
hingehören wo man nicht sagen was jetzt
bin ich aber drei Minuten eher als die
Marder Entscheidung verkündet worden ist
war der macron weil er die weil die die
Zeit nicht eingehalten in einer halben
Stunde eher dann wurde ein riesen Tamtam
gemacht dass er gesagt hat oder ein
bisschen eher ein bisschen eher aber die
beiden hatten sich die beiden haben sich
die beiden haben sich in der Sache
verständlich ich sage immer
Kommunikation kann man immer besser
machen aber der entscheidende Punkt ist
doch die Sache am Ende muss doch die
Entscheidung vernünftig sein und das ist
Bedenken in einer europäischen Staaten
gerade gesagt die sind in der
Bevölkerung
weil ich heute tatsächlich ein bisschen
telefoniert habe in Brüssel und da ist
glaube ich nicht nur die aktuelle
Entscheidung ein Problem sondern die
ganzen vergangenen Monate weil da bei
ganz vielen europäischen Partnern nach
wie vor der Eindruck ist die deutschen
bewegen sich erst an der allerletzten
Minute wenn wirklich der Druck so groß
ist dass es nicht anders geht also
dieses
zurückhaltende abwägende wie sie sagen
würden besonders wird auch wahrgenommen
als mangelnde Führung mangelndes
vorangehen und ja auch
mangelnde Unterstützung so ist das
zwischen dem was wir machen und dem wie
wir wahrgenommen werden das ist in
Teilen orchestriert die peace Party
haben sie schon Partei haben sie schon
erwähnt in Polen aber es ist eben eine
wirklich veritable Sorge wenn sie durch
Mittel und Osteuropa Reisen es ist eben
nicht nur eine Partei die Deutschland
gerade zum Ziel erkoren hat wegen des
Wahlkampfes sondern es ist ein weit
verbreitetes Gefühl
Panzern die für die Ukraine angeblich
nicht taugen verkaufen die USA gerade
hunderte an Warschau können die Polen
auch deshalb so gerne und so freiwillig
Leopards zur Verfügung stellen
das erstmal ein Vorwand denn alle
Probleme die das Pentagon ins Feld
geführt hat also das Gerät ist zu
schwierig zu modernen zu schwer falsche
Treibstoff als ich das damals gehört hat
habe ich mich selber doch gefragt
warum haben wir denn dann 2000 Panzer
selber die Ägypter nutzen denn viele
andere Dutzende andere Länder haben den
Abrams im Einsatz
insofern
waren das alles nur vor wenn der die man
seitens der Administration vorgebracht
hat weil sie einfach die Entscheidung
nicht treffen wollten und weil diese
Ausflüchte so durchsichtig waren war das
dann auf einmal so dass die politischen
Entscheidungen auch wieder schneller
durchsetzbar waren als man gesagt hat
gut wir liefern
soll heißen
die Administration waren nicht willens
diesen nächsten Schritt zu unternehmen
und dann haben sie natürlich
festgestellt dass die einzige
Möglichkeit für Deutschland
darin bestehen würde und
das hat er Frau poliere richtig gesagt
das ist ein notwendig war vielleicht
auch mal die Bestände aus den anderen
Ländern freizugeben und das war der
Grund warum der Präsident dann gesagt
hat okay dann machen wir es eben auch
wenn das die Möglichkeit ist um die
Barrieren seitens von Berlin zu
beseitigen dann machen die das also auch
eine politische Entscheidung war als
also genauso wie ich glaube das ist auch
diese Vorwände gegeben hat diese
Entschuldigungen als man es nicht tun
wollte und das war eben in aller erster
Linie militärische Gründe und auch
obwohl es klar war dass es mehr ein
symbolische aktuell hätten würde die
Abrams jetzt zu liefern wenn glauben sie
das
oder machen diese Panzer wirklich so
einen Unterschied ist die Frage
ja ja mehr als symbolisch
ja
sie werden etwas
erreichen ich glaube in den nächsten
Monaten den nächsten drei Monaten bitte
Ukraine ihre nächste Gegenoffensive
starten und dazu brauchen sie eine große
Panzer Streitmacht drei bis vier
Brigaden mit denen sie auch die
Verteidigungslinien der Russen
durchbrechen können und ein Großteil
davon wird natürlich damit zu tun haben
dass es
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge gibt auf der Seiten
der Ukraine die auch russische Gerät
kommen können sozusagen im Kampf aber
gleichzeitig kommen ja Leoparden dann
nicht nur aus einzelnen Ländern sondern
von mehreren Finnland beispielsweise
auch da können jetzt schon die
ukrainischen Soldaten anfangen
ausgebildet zu werden wenn sie dann
bereit sind in zwei oder drei Monaten
wenn diese Kampfpanzer dann auch auf dem
Gefechtsfeld für die Ukraine wirken
können die Abrams da ist es aber leider
so dass sie deutlich zu spät kommen
werden auch auf die Art und Weise wie
die Administration sich das vorgenommen
hat diese Entscheidung umzusetzen acht
bis zehn Monate ist da die Rede also bei
jedem dieser Frühjahr ist Offensive
heben wir helfen sie noch nicht wir
haben schon erwähnt ich spiele mal ganz
schnell zwei drei Zitate ein äh es war
gerade diese Entscheidung verkündet und
schon geht es um
Kampfjets und langstreckend
die Ukraine braucht Langstreckenraketen
und wir müssen erreichen dass die
Ukraine mit Flugzeugen beliefert wird
Halleluja Jesus Christus und nun liebe
Verbündete lasst uns eine starke
Kampfjet Koalition für die Ukraine auf
die Beine stellen mit F16 und F35
Eurofightern und Tornados Rafal und
gritenjets und allem was ihr der Ukraine
liefern könnt
jetzt F16 ja ich übernehme das
[Musik]
da ist wieder die Frage zunächst an den
Militärs nach London wir hatten James
den Admiral James der wildes vor 14
Tagen bei uns in der Sendung und der
sagte ja klar diese mit 29 müsste man
jetzt eigentlich die Ukraine schicken
wenn man möchte dass die Ukraine
möglichst schnell gewinnen sagen sie das
auch
wichtig ist aber dass wir entscheiden
müssen wollen wir dass die Ukraine
gewinnen genau das ist das Problem
darüber welche Art von Waffensystemen
welche Flugzeuge welche Panzer geliefert
werden sollen welche Luftabwehr zur
Einsatz kommen soll die größere Frage
tatsächlich wo Ring besteht unsere
strategische Zielsetzungen und das ist
ganz wichtig das ist gewählte
Zivilbeamte also ein Bundeskanzlerin
Präsident und so weiter
diejenigen sind die Zellen
entscheiden müssen wo das Ziel liegt und
wenn sie sagen wir möchten dass die
Ukraine gewinnt dann müssen wir alles
liefern um dieses Ziel zu erreichen und
dazu gehören natürlich kann
auch Langstrecken Präzisionswaffen damit
die Krim nicht mehr haltbar ist dass die
Russen dort nicht mehr bleiben können
auf der Kremmen und so können wir der
Ukraine beim Gewinnen helfen
und auch wieder die Souveränität über
das gesamte Hoheitsgebiet erreichen
in unserer Sendung gesagt dass das das
Ziel bleiben muss die krimen nicht
militärisch zurück zu erobern aber auf
jeden Fall eben die entsprechenden
Versorgungswege für die Russen
abzuschneiden das hat er uns in der
Sendung schon mal erzählt und auch
Interviews dazu gegeben Frau Zimmermann
wir müssen zurück zu dieser Frage die
eigentlich eine Frage nach vorne ist
nämlich sind dann die Kampfjets und die
Langstreckenraketen das nächste dem Sie
zustimmen werden und dass sie fordern
werden also wir müssen ein bisschen
aufpassen dass wir gerade noch der
Diskussion die wir intern geführt haben
nicht bevor wir überhaupt das aus also
sozusagen die Panzer in Bewegung gesetzt
haben ausgebildet haben nicht hier eine
zweite Diskussion aufmachen was ich
glaube dass wir eine Strategie brauchen
in der Tat wie könnte ein Kampf Aussehen
in den nächsten Monaten die Jahreszeit
verändert sich was wollen wir erreichen
und was benötigen wir dazu ich sehe
keine deutschen Kampfjets über der
Ukraine weil das bedeutet das kann
natürlich ein General besser erläutern
dass man natürlich auch russische
Stellungen auf russischen Gebiet
angreifen muss damit diese nicht die
Flugzeuge vom Himmel holen und das ist
natürlich eine andere qu Qualität die
Tatsache dass wir sozusagen Flugzeuge
ist nicht so dass wir daran schwimmen
ukrainischen Piloten zur Verfügung
stellen auch das ist ja die Frage denn
da sitzt ja kein deutscher Pilot drin
das sehe ich momentan noch nicht
gegebenenfalls in das andere Nationen
aber an der Stelle bin ich äußerst
zurückhaltend
rote Linie Herr alt ist da eine rote
Linie oder haben wir keine wie Herr
Mütze nicht von der SPD sagt denken Sie
das auch das möglich sein ich will von
einer Reise
verstehen einer ganz anderen Linie reden
wir diskutieren in der letzten
Viertelstunde zumindest immer noch nach
dem altrömischen Motto wenn du Frieden
willst musst du den Krieg vorbereiten
wir vergessen die entscheidende Frage
wenn du Frieden willst musst du den
Frieden vorbereiten und wie kriegen wir
das hin